splatter and louis c.k are just the
latest in a long and growing line of
high-profile individuals publicly
accused of sexual misconduct in the wake
of the allegations against Harvey
Weinstein the flood of accusations has
opened up a national discussion on
sexual harassment and sexual assault for
more on these developments we are dont
joined by dr. Gail Saltz she is a
clinical associate professor of
psychiatry at New York Presbyterian
Hospital good morning good morning Gail
we have seen a seismic shift in the
landscape around sexual assault and
sexual harassment what do you make of it
I think what people have to understand
is that this is about power this is not
about sex this is about powerful people
men and women but mostly men because
they're mostly in positions of power
going after vulnerable young victims who
are in junior positions who cannot
necessarily say something about it and
this is about humiliation and shame and
people have stayed quiet because it is
humiliating that's the point of it it is
to make the person feel shamed and even
potentially guilty as if maybe did I do
something here which is why it's so
difficult to speak out why it's taken
years for often women to say something
and why it's taken a crowd to break the
ice to make this a watershed moment to
not feel alone oh they think usually
victims feel very alone if you don't
feel alone you feel like I maybe I can
say something now can i when you talk
about shame is there not some shame that
the this the the Predators themselves
feel when you look at the louis c.k and
the Harvey Weinstein allegations there
seems to be almost self-loathing
behavior in in some of those instances
you know there may be insecurity behind
which you know connotes sort of a
narcissism like I am insecure and the
only way I can feel more powerful which
I need to feel right is to exert this
upon someone else to humiliate shame
them to make them less than me to push
them down to control them to prove that
I am the most powerful to myself and so
psychologically that maybe
it's going on whether these people have
any insight into what they did and why
they did that and therefore feel any
personal shame you know I don't know
sometimes people have sociopathy
involved with this and they really don't
have empathy for others truly that's
like a chip missing and they truly feel
the most important thing is gratifying
themselves and feeling that they're the
most powerful to your points about power
Gayle the actress Brit Marling and she's
a director as well wrote a piece in the
Atlantic basically saying the root of
all this was actually economic economic
disparity between men and women that
creates a power disparity that allows
this abuse to occur you agree with that
I do think there's a point there
absolutely I do think that if we had
many more women in power I'm not saying
this would be gone because women can do
this to women men have done this to men
except et cetera but since the
predominance is men doing it to women
and predominantly men are in power I do
think that if if they were a more equal
playing field you would see less of this
but it wouldn't be gone I think what
people have to understand is this is not
men versus women
this is powerful people taking advantage
of and harassing younger junior voting
people this is sort of bullying on
steroids if you will and and and that is
a phenomenon of human nature to
sometimes be sadistic to sometimes take
and in this case unfortunately erotic
pleasure and being sadistic and cruel
and suppressing someone else that's a
piece of what's going on it's not sex
per se but they may get a charge out of
it from that vantage point do you worry
about a backlash here given the number
of allegations I am hearing from some
men saying well hey if this is about men
then maybe I can't hire women or maybe I
can't be alone in an office with a woman
and frankly that is a defensive cop-out
something in the system needs to change
we need to have reporting systems that
are different parents need to educate
sons and daughters about this issue and
to say well defensively then I'm not
going to hire women will only make the
problem worse we need to change at
occasion and the system coming up dr.
Gail Saltz thank you so much for being
with us